first congratulations on not crashing
the car on your directorial debut
let's start with that um i am curious
though
what do you wish you knew on the first
or in pre-production
that you now know after making your
first film
there just will never be enough time
um the days the days go by so
fast and you're what
uh and trying to keep up with everything
is
massively difficult and my my hats off
to
a good example is just i i remember i
boarded out the
the first few weeks of the shoots and
then just started to fall behind and
you know it's it's it's it's a marathon
making a film and
uh so difficult to stay ahead that
um it's a 24-hour job that i you know i
knew it was going gonna be a lot but i
had no
idea that it was gonna you know take
that much of
everything which i'm totally glad it was
it was an amazing experience but
um that's the to answer that question
that i did not see that coming
everyone i speak to who makes movies all
talks about the same thing which is that
it's just really difficult to make your
pages sometimes especially because
you shot your movie on location and
you're not like on a sound stage for
like at the train
you know what i mean like yeah it's
crazy you go you go uh
i've listened to a podcast with uh
i think it was with noah bomback and and
they were talking about like where you
go to bed at night and
you don't you don't you don't think you
know what you got that then
you're like did i get everything i need
to get today and then the next day
you know nowadays because you know old
days they would go screen the dailies
when they shot on film
and you'd be able to look at the dailies
with everybody and go like okay god
now you get like an ipad and you're like
in between takes scrambling just
look at your the previous day going did
we get everything did i get it okay
great
and so uh it's yeah it's it's uh
but it's also there was a lot of joy you
got to use guns n roses in your trailer
and in the movie and that is not
an easy thing to do as far as i can tell
uh
was that was that you and jason that
made that happen was that netflix
you know so uh one of the writers will
staples put that
into the script um and yeah he
he had it in that opening sort of her
singing to it which i which was
so great to put into it um
so we knew it was going to be in there
but if i so netflix they actually
told us you know we were doing the
trailer we had two
um we had two uh cut
trailers to two different musics and one
was guns and roses and
guns and roses we were uh afraid i was
afraid of using gun
or liking guns and roses because i knew
it was going to be impossible to get it
because a was going to be probably super
expensive and they
they were notorious for saying no to
stuff so
i was even afraid to even just consider
it and uh
i'll tip my hat to netflix marking scott
stuper and everyone there that
they just decided no worry we want this
for the trailer and we're gonna get it
so i i don't know how they did but i'm
so glad they did because
it's perfect i was going to make a joke
about they just dropped the uh the dump
truck of cash
and said please i probably
probably something like that yes you've
worked with jason for a long time
what do you think would surprise people
to learn about jason that perhaps they
don't know
i think you know it was part of the
reason i wanted to do this film is
there's this versatility to him
uh and this side to him that you don't
see
because he's either playing a superhero
or he's playing
called drago or he's playing baba boss
in like these sort of
sci-fi worlds and he has
so much humanity to him uh as a person
and he's such a regular guy um
so this and the character in the film is
such a regular guy
he's not like some next military he's
just this regular
you know pittsburgh worker and uh
i hope you know i'm looking forward to
people seeing that you know that side
of jason because i don't think he's this
performance i don't think anyone's seen
this sort of performance or this side of
him
in a film there's a i i think that
specifically if you want to get specific
when he's in the hospital and he's in
the hallway and he's like losing it
because he's just
lost his wife um you know that's a very
emotional performance for him can you
talk about filming that scene
and maybe pulling that performance out
of him or was he just ready to go
he was ready to go i mean it was we had
talked about it leading up to it
um we knew how we wanted to block it and
shoot it
and um you know obviously a performance
like that you're not going to get like
you know 10 takes out of so the the
the weight on shooting that was just
knowing that i'm going to have
only maybe a handful of opportunities to
be able to
shoot this to get it and and of course
you know
we decided that we wanted to have a
handheld camera follow him through
through an actual hospital
uh so it wasn't a set so it even made it
more difficult to
and you don't want to go out of focus or
whatnot so um but
it it really tied itself together i
think the you know
forget would take it was an earlier take
i mean we we only did maybe
five four ticks of that um and he
i of the the entire set was just had
tears in their eyes and
you know um it was so
uh gutter role in his performance and
uh like him crying and you know just
him doing it as a character but then
also seeing your friend have to break
down like that
in in that way was that made you it made
you
made the eyes swell up a little bit yeah
it felt very
raw and uh i can't imagine doing more
than two takes of that
that i guess that's what you get paid
for for acting yeah
no he was great he was he was like he
just he was in the zone um
i you know like those sort of
performances that's
that's all the actor you know like you
can't you can discuss
you can talk have conversations and
discuss with what you know discuss with
them but when it's
it's go time it's like you know
it's they they're just going to do what
they're going to do i think that one of
the
the more impressive things is the uh the
stadium
sequence you have like 800 extras 80
cars
this is like a massive sequence um
what is it like trying to put this thing
together
it was that was week two of our shoot
and
uh it was uh i mean it was just a lot of
prep
we we i boarded that out um
you know you've been we've shot it for
uh i believe a week and you just knew we
started we shot it in order
so you just knew like okay the scene
starts on the bridge and he's going to
have to end up on the rooftop by the end
of it
and we just mapped it out of of
going through the reach but it was we
we walked that stadium countless times
with with tech scouts and crew and just
meticulously planned it
uh where the cameras were gonna go
because
it was something that it was gonna be
such a challenge to just get through it
all
because there's so much ground to cover
that it just didn't want to have to
worry about
you know where am i going to put the
camera now it's like we really wanted to
be able to just
move through it uh i'm always obsessed
with talking about the editing room
because it's where it all comes together
uh can you can you can you talk about
like did you have a much longer
like first cut uh i'm sure i'm always
curious about that kind of stuff
yeah well we were so we barely made we
finished shooting two weeks before the
pandemic
so we got into with we had to edit the
film
and remotely like like a lot of films
that we're starting to find out right
now but it was
we had our challenges um but we went
through
it the editorial because of the story
was a difficult one you know it was
it's because of the reveal and how we're
setting it up
and we really wanted to make sure this
this reveal was always character driven
uh and story driven and not some sort of
cheap trick of
hey we tricked you it's not this
character for that
and um you have to try i think you got
to try a bunch of different stuff to
land in the right area it's not
not somewhere that is going to be you
know um
uh come out like the first time and go
like hey we got it we knocked it out of
the park on the first cut it was
you always like it was always forward
progress where you you would
do a cut and look at it and be like okay
it's great
but this could be better and then and
it's just constantly
um kind of having those conversations as
we go through
our editor we had an editor um mike
mccusker who
edited ford versus ferrari and um
amazing editor and uh who really really
brought the
brought the narrative to life so did you
end up with a lot of deleted scenes or
no
we did we had you know we ended up
we shot some scenes that were sort of
expositionary
about the sort of to build up the bad
guys or whatever
and we just felt like it was not needed
you know it was
um all these sort of you think you the
audience needs
sort of uh an understanding of
of some things about the villains and
then you realize no they don't
let's just keep the train moving uh i
gotta stop there i'm just gonna say
again congrats on your first movie i
hope you're making something again soon
ah thank you so much i appreciate i hope
you liked it